it's Friday and that means it's time for
Friday Folly and for that we turn to Fox
News contributor Raymond Royo all right
Raymond there was nothing on the
president's schedule today shocking as
that may be but his last event of the
week was um to um marry Duty on the
south lawn what it was Laura look it was
heartwarming to see the president light
the National Christmas Tree especially
since his lights have been out for so
long but there were some let's call them
outages along the way if you're the
White House Advance Team it's probably a
good idea to put the teleprompter not so
close to the bulletproof glass so that
the audience can read it along with the
president no Jill and I are honored to
welcome you to the National Christmas
Tree Lighting thanks to Interior
secretary Deb Holland and the National
Park Service Foundation they're the one
doing this oh yes you can see it it's
like a
decoration yes it is well not yeah and
and the big moment that was supposed to
everyone supposed to wait for to gather
around and do a group countdown what he
couldn't he couldn't even wait that long
[Music]
hello
five
four
3 2
[Applause]
one well no buildup at all I think you
call that premature illumination Laura
uh if if the timing was a little off at
least one U tide tradition was protected
the president performed his trademark
where's the exit dance oh
[Music]
no what was that even the music stopped
well and then he stops is it does he
think maybe he thinks it's just a one
long game of musical chairs you're
supposed to stop when the Music Stops I
mean I don't know peculiar Christmas
spirit I'm granting you three wishes
make them quick oh thank you Mrs Claus
look my first wish is that Pro
Palestinian protesters would stop using
tree lighting ceremonies and Christmas
events as a staging ground for their
protest now this was the scene from
Columbia University where during the
tree lighting ceremony protesters cancel
[Applause]
Joy
Live's for
C OCC isra OCC I love I I love they
think they can cancel Joy Laura you
can't cancel Joy you're not the minister
of joy and this idea you heard them say
there's no room for celebration I'm
sorry there is and our religious uh
Embrace and expression of Christmas is
not your free pass to Stage a
demonstration do that somewhere else at
another time sorry they just this is
their whole goal they don't they don't
they don't they want the Jewish faith
they don't want the Christian faith they
don't want any of that that's not what
it's all about for them they want to
swamp all of it there were also a group
of seven protesters arrested near
Rockefeller Center during their tree
ceremony protest on your own time don't
re ruin our family or holiday
celebrations with your protest okay I
want to go on to my second wish lore I
wish we had more magazine covers like
this and less magazine covers like this
one features Shannon dor who's been
waging an incredible inspiring battle
against cancer savoring every moment of
life and the other features a publicity
Hound who gets coverage for getting
coverage what does Dylan Mulaney do
except talk about Dylan mulany I'll take
Shar and DH any day what has happened to
Forbes I mean I don't know I mean I
guess there's a sound bite I just Ste I
don't know a lot about cancer people put
you out to pasture at a very early age
you're like done you're retired and
we're not we have such a different
outlook on life we're just so grateful
for every second every hour every day
that we get to be here oh good good for
her hero yeah we need to hear more of
that finally Laura I wish stores would
stop accommodating looting look at this
video from earlier this week the guard
just let these people come into to take
whatever they want why not let them try
on shoes and get their sizes from the
back maybe lter gift trapping could be
next this is a nightmare no it's
consumer reparations Raymond that's what
they are calling it in Chicago consumer
reparations all right Raymond um we miss
you in New York you're not here I know
you're here earlier this week but where
you headed this weekend with the uh big
band I'm going to Dallas House of Blues
Sunday night with Jose Feliciano then
Cleveland and and onto Nashville Raymond
Royal christmas.com we're going to keep
it marry and bright live can't wait so
are you singing felis Navidad are you
doing the duet are you part of the I am
singing with the man himself with the
man himself it's going to be a legendary
night well he's amazing he's such a
wonderful person as is his family and as
long as you don't get it near a guitar
Raymond I'm I'm excited for you that's
going to be awesome raym congrats number
one Jazz album in the country congrats
Raymond hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else